rock'n'roll c'est quoi alors viens drôle
c'est une chose qui n'existe plus ça
s'est arrêté quand en 59 compresse la
partie des rebelles campent du noir sont
affectés par sa vie l'amour c'est quoi
ça ça lui au moment même en bois se
forme une heure je suis pas d'amour je
crois que beaucoup d'ennuis et dieu dans
tout ça
ben justement ces dunes et voilà alors
que la pose et l'a mis la main là où
l'homme n'avait pas mis les pieds
donc il est très important de savoir
grimper aux murs quand on est mieux
lander de ton d'humour excellent est-ce
que tu prends en dieu j'aimerais bien
vraiment bien mais continent - les
corrections de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux